hey youtubers is Charlie happy Friday so
many awesome things happening today so
my friends made a movie this summer that
you can actually go see Nick's Monday
called the hive I'm gonna explain what
that's all about
then we also got our first look at
Hawkman and Hawkgirl from legends of
tomorrow and there's a whole bunch of
new flash footage so here's the deal
with my friends movie it's gonna be in
theaters on Monday night you can
actually go see it it's a horror film so
I'm gonna play the trailer right now
just so you guys can see it first told
you about my feelings for you
this probably seems pretty familiar to
some of you who are watching Teen Wolf
this year a lot of awesome body horror
going on like things being cut off
things being stuck places they're not
supposed to go then you get like the
reaction shots like this like oh my god
just because this is such a huge deal I
would consider it a personal favor if
you guys pooped your pants in the
theater out of sheer terror
it will go video-on-demand eventually
but you can actually go and see it in a
theater on Monday night I know we've
been talking about arrow season for a
lot the last couple days so hive
actually rings some bells this actually
does share a little bit in common with
hive from the comics like the more
recent new 52 comics
we're in Superman gets mind-controlled
by queen bee a little bit I mean in the
in the case of this movie it's an alien
virus but you get the idea
you know it's almost October when
they're jump-scares in almost every
single trailer you see Monday night is a
limited theatrical release so I'll put a
link in the description so you guys can
check her there's actually like a
theater that's gonna be playing it near
you if any of you guys haven't seen it
there is actually a long tradition of
killing me in YouTube videos that goes
back to like 2007 my friends used to run
the Indy mogul channel and they would
they do a lot like DIY films stuff so
they would put me in their short films
and they would just kill me every single
time I got shot in the head I think I
got splattered once I got vaporized
another time I was kind of like the Sean
Bean of Indy mogul for a little while
maybe I could turn that into like a
second Hollywood career so more awesome
stuff happening I'm gonna do a separate
video about hawkman and hawkgirl but
it's just like one more reason to poop
your pants today this is what they look
like now obviously you don't see wings
everyone's asking about the wings
they're gonna be mostly CG and if you
wonder why just look at the Michael
Shanks version from Smallville and
you'll be like oh okay
yeah definitely do them CG I got mad
love for Michael Shanks and the
Smallville people I'm a huge stargate
fan but I'd really rather them go with a
look that they've gone with for the
flash I feel like the way they've done
everything with the newer DC shows is
way better than they did on Smallville
what are the important things of
rebooting characters on TV is that you
evolve the style and if you want a
nitpick the helmets that are wearing are
way more comic-book accurate than the
Smallville helmet was ancient Egyptian
curse haute couture never looked so good
I know way more about what's going on
with Hawkgirl than I do about Hawkman
but they did say that Hawkman will
understand their history he'll he'll
totally understand the cycle of death
and rebirth
whenever they meet though hawkgirl will
have no idea and that that'll happen
during the flash season two during the
first half of the season so it'll be
like running into your old girlfriend
only she doesn't remember that you guys
used to be married hundreds and hundreds
of times there's also some new flash
footage with patty spivot so I'm
actually gonna do a video for that next
just because she's gonna be one of the
best new female characters I'm so
excited about her be sure to subscribe
to get everything I should have that
flash video up in at least like three
maybe four hours should be up by this
afternoon it's gonna be a really awesome
weekend there's actually there's some
new Doctor Who footage too but that's
like a completely separate thing I'll do
a separate video for that so happy
Friday everybody have an awesome time
hopefully you guys haven't had too many
tests so far something you should be
back in school by now so while you guys
wait for everything you can click here
for the latest arrow and flash trailer
and you can click here to learn all
about patty spivot from the comics thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight